family offices have been around for
years your article tells us they have
exploded why exactly mark so family
offices are basically businesses set up
by people who have so much money that
they need to hire their own staff what a
shame
exactly they needed to run their homes
or multiple homes to handle their taxes
and invest their money so it lasts over
generations and as we've seen a number
of billionaires expand around the globe
we've also seen a number of them set up
family offices so give us some prominent
examples so you have Sergey Brin you
have Bill Gates the for the founder of
Microsoft and now we're seeing in recent
years some hedge fund managers and
private equity managers as well
conflicts are there any what are they so
when you look at the family offices that
are being set up by hedge fund managers
several things come up as potential for
conflicts of interest when we talk to
people because hedge fund managers who
have family offices are also running the
money of outside investors so that's
where it gets a little trickier so the
potential for conflicts of interests
that have been raised are if you have
the family office based in the same
place as your hedge fund
how are you allocating the expenses for
office staff research support staff how
is that being paid for
are there any overlapping investments if
you invest in a small company and it
grows into a bigger one that the hedge
fund wants to invest in how do you
handle that and then also the question
of how much money of the managers is
still in the hedge fund because many
managers attract investors by saying I'm
a great investor come invest with me and
I'm putting my own money in the fund -
it sounds like the problem is that an
investment from would face with
proprietary trading desks versus trading
on behalf of their clients yeah and many
of the hedge fund managers that we
talked to said they have strict policies
related to trades and also that they pay
all the expenses for staff but this is
something that investors don't always
ask questions about and they may want it
speaking of not asking questions it
seems to be a bit secretive as well why
is that so yeah so the world of family
offices is extremely secretive some of
it is people are protective of their own
families and their kids and some of it
is that they don't always want to tell
people when they're buying a real estate
property or setting up a trust and
seeding it with certain things for their
grandchildren but things like that
don't folks want that
Transparency if they're in trusting you
and they're investing their own money
with you don't they want to know what's
going on so I think that's one of the
questions that's been raised right is
how many of these hedge fund managers
have actually said to their investors
hey I have this other legal entity on
the side this is how I handle the
investments in that and it's separate
from the firm in this way in that way
well in terms of disclosure what about
regulation how involved are federal
regulators in all of this if at all yes
so this is one of the things about
family offices in general they are even
loot the more loosely regulated than
private funds like a hedge fund or a
private equity fund that's some of the
appeal to very wealthy people right if
you're only managing the money within
the family office for you know blood
relatives then you don't have to
register with the SEC which means you
don't have to disclose your assets under
management or some of the investments
you're making you don't have to disclose
for perhaps perhaps 5% stakes or 10%
stakes you do still have to follow some
of the SEC guidelines on that or for
filing a 13 F if you have more than a
hundred million in public equities is
this on the agency's radars are they
taking a look at this as well have there
been any controversies that have hit
their radar screen so we did ask the SEC
about this they said they certainly are
noticing the growth of family offices
and looking into it and mainly their
area focus would be are there any
overlapping investments and if there are
how and when is that disclosed all right
Margaret Collins of Bloomberg News thank
you so much and of course you can read
Margaret's story on Bloomberg comm